at a time where nearly everybody has a
camera personal videos like Christian
Cooper's are playing a crucial role in
the fight to end racial inequality in
America they reveal violent racially
charged incidents that might have gone
unnoticed in the past such as the police
killing of George Floyd sick of that
tape - and the shooting death of a Matar
Berry chased and confronted by white men
while apparently jogging in his own
neighborhood
now all these help investigators in
fueled public outrage Trey Johnson
writes about issues of race culture and
identity he joins us from Philadelphia
to discuss hello Trey Johnson nice to
have you on this one these videos I'm
hanging in there I'm hanging in there
these videos that capture racially
charged incidents are not new but there
does seem to be a different conversation
in the public these days why do you
think that is we all remember Rodney
King and how horrible that was yeah I
mean I do you think the conversation
feels a little bit different i tribute
some of that to the pandemic I think
there is a funnel of attention that's
being focused on things that are right
in front of you right now because a lot
more conventional distractions have
fallen away and I think I give a lot of
credit to protesters I think there have
been a lot of peaceful marches in the
streets that have elevated the senseless
killings to the public conscience and
now people are forced to as they're
constantly engaged in social media and a
lot of their devices around the clock
even more so during the pandemic I think
it makes it hard to run away from a lot
of these issues as they're happening
right now also I think because approach
has to are multi-generational and
multiracial that also makes a difference
do you generally speaking do you think
that these videos help a situation or do
you think they escalate a situation I
think look I think unfortunately they
have their part of the long history of
archival stories and images that haven't
been at the backbone of the American
experience for black Americans which is
that you know senseless injustice
happens to us routinely and so these
stories and these deaths
unfortunately help to maintain a
conversation around what's happening
around about race in America that if
is helpful is like you know it's a tough
word to use considering that we're
talking about death here but I do think
there is a benefit to making people see
that these things that we are talking
about aren't aren't just made up they're
actually happening in some bizarre
circumstances at times yeah and for a
lot of people trades you know it's been
eye-opening I like in your Washington
Post op-ed you wrote how many of your
black friends are now receiving requests
from white people about what to do how
can I help and you said a lot of times
it's very contradictory I like what you
said you but you're told to step up no
step back read no listen protests not
protests check on black friends leave us
alone ask for help or do the work so you
said it can be very confusing but you
said what most people need to do is
start with a self audit what do you mean
yeah so in that Washington Post I say
when black people are in pain white
people joined book clubs I talked about
how like one of the places that I
believe that change happens is when
people go to a place of discomfort that
place of discomfort often means looking
at in your own particular past where is
an opportunity or where was it a place
in time intentionally or unintentionally
you might have caused some type of
economic or spiritual or social or
professional harm to a black person that
was in your life and I think it's about
like unpacking what happened in that
moment and then thinking about what are
the patterns that might be true about
that moment that you might be
maintaining still today and how do you
find the resources the support the
conversations what have you to start
disrupting a lot of those patterns but I
believe a lot of these things about
these system changes really start with a
lot opportunity for it to changes to
start with the individual you know the
data shows that the black lives matter
movement is tracking to be one of the
biggest in history where would you like
to see it go from here I love America
sure Brooks Mayer Keisha bottoms rather
in Atlanta who said you know a protest
is not a plan approach us has to have a
purpose
where would you like to see it go from
here you know I would one thing I would
quickly underscore is that protests
always have a purpose they are sometimes
maybe unclear to people who are
on the outside or on the margins of
protests but I've been part of many and
they've always served a purpose to
elevate a lot of conversations and to
recognize the lives I've been lost in
terms of where I would like to see it go
I mean I think sky's the limit you know
I think there's so much that needs to
happen in terms of increasing
representation in so many of our most
influential positions of power in
government and entertainment and
publishing everywhere and I also think
to a lot of this is about like how do we
start disrupting a lot of the like very
ingrained segregation patterns that
exist in the country that serve to just
further make anemic access to resources
for a lot of black and brown citizens in
this country so things like that like I
think I think a great example of this is
the movement to talk about defunding
police to reallocate those resources to
providing much more nourishing
supportive resources at the school level
at the mental health level housing a lot
of the ways that we know can kind of
increase or stymie the mobility of
Americans and in their everyday life but
it's especially using those resources a
reallocation to those resources to go
into the black and brown communities
that are routinely underserved all right
Trey Johnson you said it very well
you're right a protest always does have
a purpose but I go back to mayor bottoms
point about you know protests has got to
have a plan we have to do more than just
march in the streets I thank you for
pointing it out and giving us some
direction thanks a lot